bombendrohung stromausfall oder
börsencrash danach leidet jemand mehr
unter zu niedrigen blutdruck in sachen
börse ist es wieder mal soweit seit dem
wochenende sind die kurse weltweit
gehöre ich auf talfahrt geradezu
unvermeidlich
corona virus und die börse was wird aus
unserem geld jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix-runde herzlich willkommen liebe
zuschauer bei uns meine gäste im studio
city heitmann ist bei uns moderatoren
wirtschaftsjournalistin bekannt als ard
börsenexpertin hermann josef tenhagen
ist chefredakteur des online magazins
finanztest und gegen die bezeichnung
verbraucherschützer das sicherlich auch
nichts einzuwenden
professor wolfgang gerke ist
kapitalmarkt spezialist und präsident
des bayerischen finanz zentrums in
münchen und ingo schröder ist bei uns
finanzcoach auch die finanzberater
brauchen mal jemanden der sie berät und
das machen sich ist das fragt man sich
was wird an den börsen da gerade zurecht
gerückt was schon viel zu lange schiff
war also in erster linie ist eine
situation entstanden die eine große
panik ausgelöst hat ein unwohlsein bei
allen weil eben unglaublich viele
momente jetzt zusammengekommen sind das
oft was sie ansprechen das ist im grunde
ein rücksetzer auf den viele gewartet
haben weil wir eine unglaubliche rallye
fast hatten die haben viele darunter
abgehakt dass sie gesagt haben das
vorher lief schlecht jetzt haben wir ein
tolles jahr 2019 gehabt aber tatsächlich
haben wir uns schon in schwindelnden
höhen bewegt und dieser rücksetzer dass
es der den viele erwartet haben
was jetzt der zugang ist eben das corona
virus was eben nicht nur eine
medizinische sondern eine
wirtschaftliche komponente mit sich
bringt eben gerade dadurch dass china so
stark betroffen ist
dadurch dass dadurch handelsströme
betroffen sind und natürlich eben jetzt
auch hier viele unternehmen und dazu
kommt jetzt noch dazu eben diese ölkrise
also die krise des ölpreises muss man
sagen denn für die märkte muss das gar
nicht schlecht
ein unglück kommt selten allein herr
schröder vielen menschen ist die börse
trotz aller transparenz da täglich auf
dem parkett auch ein bisschen unheimlich
so ein crash der ist aber nicht gerade
eine vertrauensbildende maßnahmen
definitiv nicht man muss halt immer
schauen wo man das vertrauen vorher
gebildet hat denn wenn man
kapitalanlagen hat egal in welcher form
ob es jetzt etf sind wie sie auch häufig
empfohlen mit oder aktien ist wenn man
die frage weiß ich vorher schon bescheid
wie von risiken an den kapitalmärkten
lauern und 30 wegen der finanzkrise war
oder in der ölkrise für die älteren oder
dot com blase und dort lauern in
verluste auch mal von bis zu 50 prozent
müsste die börse nicht überhaupt
generell mal entmystifiziert werden in
guten wie in bösen auch die rhetorik ich
habe schon zweimal das wort crash
gebraucht dh der bildlich gesprochen
alles liegt in trümmern und
zerschmettert am boden muss da
vielleicht der börse auch irgendwie eine
ganz andere eine ganz andere optik
gegeben werden und eine ganz andere art
wie man nach außen erscheint achso wir
besser aber eine sehr plastische sprache
gehabt und die muss man nicht kaputt
machen
ich glaube nicht dass es im sprach frage
ist sondern es ist mehr eine
informations frage wir müssen lernen
auch schon in der schule wiener börse
funktioniert und das ist jetzt sage ich
ganz bewusst das ist an der börse immer
wieder einen crash geben wird und diesen
kräften wieder einen crash folgen
in der zwischenzeit kann man viel geld
verlieren und dann im crash viel geld
gewinnen sogar und ich sage das ganz
bewusst in dieser reihenfolge der bürger
ist deutschland nicht auf eingestellt er
steigt ein wenn er sieht die anderen
viel geld verdient und haben wir 2000
dann rennt dann die telekom rein und
wenn die dot.com unternehmen dann fällt
auf die nase und sagt auch nie wieder
börse nicht wenn es dann wieder oben ist
dann kommt er wieder haben gerade erlebt
jetzt nicht und dann kommt der korona
virus nick und der sagt das ist nichts
für mich nicht wieder aufs sparbuch und
dann wird da sein sparziel
lebensstandard im alter sichern die
erreichen dann haut das timing da gar
nicht richtig hin hat in hagen
ruhe ist ja eigentlich die erste anleger
pflicht beim kurssturz das allein ja
eine panik wie jetzt am montag die
situation sich fach verschönern kann
abgesehen davon dass es in diesem kurzen
sturz der kurssturz kommt das scheint ja
auch offenbar vielen sogenannten
börsenprofis nicht geläufig zu sein
also eigentlich war mein eindruck am
montag dass die panik im wesentlichen
bei den börsenprofis war deswegen und
nicht so sehr bei den kleinen anlegern
also diejenigen die in den letzten
jahren da angelegt haben viele von denen
jedenfalls haben begriffen dass das eine
langfristige anlage ist die haben diese
sparpläne für ets da gibt's das
anderthalb millionen sparplänen die
haben sparpläne gezeichnet das heißt
jeden monat wieder 100 oder 200 euro die
haben gar nicht so sehr
und die haben auch nicht so panisch
reagiert weil die reagieren gar nicht so
schnell
das ist das erste mal und das zweite ist
wir tun natürlich in unserer art wie wir
darüber reden immer ein stück weit etwas
dazu also ich war ein bisschen erstaunt
dass wir um die mitte februar corona war
ja schon ein großes problem die
volksrepublik china einer 16 17 18
prozent der weltwirtschaft steht
praktisch still und wir allen an der
börse von hochstand zu hoch stand was
das kann ja kann man eigentlich vorher
nicht verstehen genauso wie man jetzt
die acht prozent in einem fach auch
nicht verstehen muss unbedingt und das
ist das was die leute dann sozusagen
irritiert und was sagt also wenn ich da
hingucken würde und wenn ich glauben
würde
das hat was mit rationalität zu tun dann
wird sie müssen sich ja verzweifeln also
ist es besser wenn die leute wirklich
verstehen man muster dabei sein weil man
an der wertentwicklung der firmen
weltweit dabei ist dann 15 jahre zehn
jahre 15 er möglichst marktbreit und
nicht einen einzelnen firmen und was die
brasilianer machen
dem muss man nicht unbedingt über den
weg trauen für morgen und übermorgen
also sind die groove ist eigentlich da
das problem wenn wir uns den vergangenen
montag mal ansehen
diesen kurssturz wie schlimm war der
wirklich wenn wir ihn mal vergleichen
mit der geschichte der kursstürze 2008
finanzkrise 2001 anschlag auf den world
race sind also ziehen nun 80 gab es
schon mal einen schwarzen montag 29 das
war ja anders als wir das immer lesen ja
eigentlich ein schwarzer donnerstag
wegen der zeitverschiebung zu den usa
verglichen mit diesen historischen
ereignissen wie schlimmen war dieser
kurssturz am vergangenen montag
tatsächlich
glaube dass das ein dramatischer sturz
war weil er im falschen moment kam
sie haben selber schon geschildert nicht
japan in wohlen flug und wenn wir uns
die profis anschauen die haben den dax
am jahresende zu mehr zeit bei 14.000
gesehen und jetzt wo sind wir jetzt
nicht das war für die so ein schock dass
die erstmal sich gesichert haben
und das hat es runter getrieben so jetzt
können wir sagen wenn wir das nicht mehr
machen wir sind durch das die profis
haben verrückt gespielt und wir sind
dass sie dann schnell nach unten und
schnell herum aber das wird nicht so
sein denn wir sind gerade am anfang vom
letzten endes basisszenario in den
quartalsbilanzen von den unternehmen und
der korona virus der ritter erst noch zu
schlagen das heißt also werden in diesem
jahr leider dann erleben dass das kein v
wird sondern dass das sich schon in
richtung entwickelt und insofern war es
ein sehr dramatischer ein wort kommt
auch 1 hinzu es wird über 50 prozent
heute über computer gehandelt über
computerprogramme gehandelt über ober
advisor gehandelt und die haben
eingebaute stop-loss-orders also wenn
der kurs weiter absinkt verkaufen die
automatisch und das beschleunigt so
etwas wie eine self fulfilling prophecy
letzten end ist das heißt diese
künstliche intelligenz verstärkten
diesen trend auch noch jetzt habe ich
das aber von ihnen irgendwie alles durch
die blume schon gesagt verstanden es war
so ein kurssturz mit ansage und war auch
eigentlich unabhängig von kronach
ich glaube was überrascht hat in dem
umfeld ist die geschwindigkeit
weil kursstürze in der form gab es wie
sie gerade gesagt haben immer mal wieder
aber ich glaube die geschwindigkeit wir
sind zwei wochen wo dann der montag das
resultat war das endresultat erstmal
froh wären sechs bei fast 10.000 euro
standen ich glaube das ist das was
möglich auch die profis schockt und wie
sie gar schon richtig gesagt haben das
kann durchaus mal länger dauern wenn man
sich mal historisch anschaut von der
dotcom-blase wenn man kurz vorher
eingestiegen ist wie lange es gedauert
hat bis man wieder auf plus minus null
war das hat bis zu zwölf jahre gedauert
und wenn man darauf nicht vorbereitet
ist
dann sollte man es spätestens jetzt tun
müssen wir uns auf eine längere
durststrecke einstellen
es wird länger gehen und ich also
nochmal der am zwanzigsten hatten wir
den höchststand dann haben wir in der
woche drauf schon 10 11 prozent an der
börse verloren das heißt der ghanaer
februar von serge rotzer februar gab es
in der ersten woche schon 10 11 prozent
und das war im wesentlichen war das
coroner reaktion auf italien darauf dass
corona eben nicht ein chinesisches
problem bleibt sondern tatsächlich in
europa angekommen ist und da aber das
war immer noch nicht komplett
eingepreist und also das ist einfach das
ist eine fundamentale sozusagen bewegung
in der weltwirtschaft was da jetzt
passiert da ist war monate sind
handelsströme nicht klar wie sie weiter
funktionieren werden es ist nicht klar
ob die chinesen weiter ihre sachen
kaufen wenn die chinesen die uns aus der
letzten finanzkrise rausgezogen mit 6
700 milliarden dollar programmen die
werden dass diesmal so in der form nicht
um die wären möglicherweise wieder
produzieren ja ja aber wir haben dann
richtig größeres problem so und das
heißt aber für die leute man muss den
leuten da ja reinen wein einschenken das
heißt wenn ich langfristig dabei bin ist
das alles kein problem aber es ist
keiner da bin ich völlig eigentlich ist
keine frau geschichte es ist nicht so
dass derjenige der jetzt irgendwie sieht
dass da 20 prozent - ist sozusagen jetzt
mal drei monate abwartet und dann kommt
das wieder wäre jetzt werde dieses jahr
das geld braucht oder den teil den man
dieses jahr braucht den muss man
woanders her holen oder im zweifel in
den sauren apfel beißen und sagen man
nimmt die verluste mit weil so lange man
nicht verkauft haben die verluste an und
es wird auch keine sein das wäre der
nächste buchstabe des alphabets
da geht es auch nach unten aber nicht so
schnell wieder hoch wie vor sondern hält
sich unten steigt dann wieder an sie
mein sein also das bleibt erstmal und
mittlere zeit gerechnet ist immer
wiedergekommen 11 bis heute zeit dieser
diese jahre des starken kursanstiegs in
den letzten jahren das team
kontinuierlich zum teil relativ steil
nach oben bisschen zurück aber
eigentlich im grunde hat es immer nur
eine richtung gehabt nach oben
dann ist er ein solcher fall und die
aussicht dass das noch lange so bleiben
wird natürlich eine außerordentliche
unangenehme erfahrung diese psychologie
dir was
wird das mit dem markt jetzt in nächster
zeit machen da gibt es ja nicht nur die
börsianer da gibt es eben auch die
anleger die damit geld machen wollen
ihre altersversorgung finanzieren oder
ein hausbau was wird das mit dem ganzen
mit der ganzen börse machen
also ich bin erstmal überrascht dass so
klar schon alle wissen wie es wird denn
ich finde die situation sehr
unübersichtlich 2003 haben wir das mit
sars schon mal erlebt auch ein corona
virus der dax hat 30 prozent
nachgelassen aber auch die irak-krieg im
schlepptau trotzdem hat sich der dax
sehr schneller erholt ich will nicht
sagen dass das die theorie ist die ich
habe denn diesmal ist die die epidemie
etwas deutlicher ausgeprägt aber
tatsächlich würde ich solche prognosen
gar nicht wagen dass so viele jahre
dauert
was macht das mit den anlegern das wird
sehr davon abhängen welche anleger es
geht und in was sie tatsächlich
investiert sind also wenn wir von den
großen institutionellen anlegern zum
beispiel sprechen diese nicht aus den
märkten gegangen also die grossen
pensionskassen beispielsweise die sind
aber auch nicht so stark ausgestatteten
mit aktien vorläufig dass die das schwer
bedrückt außer sie sind womöglich eben
von ihrem unternehmen abhängig das gibt
es natürlich auch die lebensversicherer
betrifft das in dich die sind natürlich
abgesichert und das ist auch weit
eingerechnet und mit eigenkapital
unterlegt die einzelnen privatanleger
die sind natürlich je nachdem ob sie ihr
geld brauchen sowieso in einer absolut
misslichen lage
daraus darf man lernen dass man in
aktien dann geht das geld nicht dringend
braucht oder mindestens den teil hat
denen man braucht denn so eine krise
zeigt man weiß einfach nicht wandern
wieder ans geld kommt aber es ist keine
unglaubliche entfernung ist müssen nicht
zehn oder 30 jahre sein dass man an sein
geld zum gleichen preis kommt denn was
wäre denn die richtige richtige
verhalten jetzt sowas kann ja wie gesagt
immer wieder passieren auch mal ein
starker sturz sollte man flucht
bevorzugen aus den märkten sich tot
stellen oder soll man strategisch
vorgehen und wenn strategisch standen
welche strategie also tot stellen nicht
da kommen noch leichter ins krankenhaus
mitbewohner verdacht aber ich glaube die
richtige strategie wäre jetzt sein
portfolio
er hat noch mal auf den prüfstand zu
stellen und für sich herauszufinden
bin ich denn überhaupt bereit und kann
ich das überhaupt ertragen so viel
risiko einzugehen
war das maximum was wir haben einen etf
zum beispiel ms word wenn man zu 100
prozent und aktien ist dann kann das
passieren mit den 50 jahren und in zehn
jahren die frage ist aber wie wenn ich
auf einer autobahn bin habe ich nur den
motor kein airbag und fand nur geradeaus
oder habe ich vielleicht ein airbag
eingebaute der diesen sturz nach unten
auch abfangen kann
und das jetzt für sich erst mal zu
überprüfen auch psychologisch kann ich
das emotional aushalten oder bin ich
einfach ins wasser rhein gesprungen und
habe mal geguckt wo es mich hintreibt
ich glaube das sollte man jetzt klären
und im zweifel mal die schwimmflügel
rausholen machen sich die leute dazu
wenig gedanken darüber wozu sie da
vielleicht bereit wären wenn ende an den
aktienmärkten etwas unangenehmes
passiert ich glaube da sind also ja die
leute aber die also von den personen von
denen es verkauft wird
ich glaube das ist im endeffekt wichtig
dass natürlich dort vorbereitet wird und
ich glaube da wird an vielen stellen ob
das jetzt bei online-anbietern robert
weise an banken beratern nur unzufrieden
das risiko ermittelt also da wird oft
die risikowahrnehmung ermittelt und wenn
sie jetzt zehn jahre mitgemacht haben
200 prozent plus im portfolio haben und
ich sehe dann trage das risiko
wenn sie sagen wo ist denn hier risiko
aber wenn sie gerade ein haus gebaut
haben familie gegründet haben und dann
fällt ihr portfolio um 20 nehmen sie
risiko ganz anders war und wenn ich sie
dann da nachfrage dann wird das
situative sehr unterschiedlich sind aber
jemand der ein haus gebaut hat und seine
raten noch abzubezahlen hat der hat doch
nicht ein großes portfolio also wenn
derjenige der das beraten bekommen hätte
im portfolio zu haben wenn er das haus
gebaut hat und das risiko da müsste man
den berater ja mal ganz schnell die
löffel lang ziehen das geht überhaupt
gibt
aber ich habe jetzt verstanden ich habe
verstanden dass man einfach darauf
achtet ob man auf das geld verzichten
kann oder nicht
das ist aber immer so also dass wenn man
also alles kurzfristig an der börse
anlegen ist ich mache das jetzt ganz
radikal ist zocken anlegen an der börse
ist erst zehn 15 jahre lange zeiträume
wissen dass man das geld über den langen
zeitraum
braucht und am kapitalmarkt da der
kapitalmarkt entwicklung partizipiert
und dazwischen gibt es auch informierte
anlage also über diese kurzen und
mittleren zeiträume aber da sage ich
immer die voraussetzung ist ein abo vom
south china morning herald man muss sich
nämlich mit südostasien mit den formen
und mit dem was in der weltwirtschaft
passiert intensiv und regelmäßig
beschäftigen
und jetzt mal ganz ehrlich so zu sagen
wie viele leute tun das denn in dieser
republik jenseits derjenigen die das
professionell tun müssen
deswegen würde ich immer sagen kapital
im aktienmarkt richtig fein
aktienindexfonds weltweit fein richtig
aber über zehn oder 15 jahre und
deswegen haben wir so arbeiten dabei
finanziert auch immer dass wir den
leuten sagen langfristig da kurzfristig
hast du ein tagesgeldkonto oder mit
ihren dispo brauchst du hast vielleicht
ein festgeld für zwei oder drei oder
fünf jahre weil du schon weist in drei
jahren will dein kind studieren oder die
letzte rate vom hauses völlig lassen
kommt gleich noch immer auf die anleger
und die börse zurück wie man sich daran
am besten verhält oder was sich
möglicherweise überhaupt ändern muss im
umgang mit der börse professor geben da
sind ja einige jetzt in mitleidenschaft
gezogen worden das ist immer so bei
einem kurssturz zunächst mal die
realwirtschaft wo liegen die gefahren
jetzt gerade in anbetracht dieses
kurssturzes und dass wir nicht genau
wissen wohin entwickelt sich der ölpreis
a/b die krone epidemie also ich bin so
pessimistisch weil ich gerade diesmal
sehe das anders als beim saas virus das
die realwirtschaft besonders stark
betroffen ist und das ist natürlich in
den perioden wo man so an der börse
denkt und das sind nicht diese langen
perioden der der altersvorsorge nicht
sondern sind mittel kurzfristigen
perioden nicht da da wird das einen
dramatischen einfluss für dieses jahr
haben und wenn man sich dieses jahr
anschaut dann haben die profis erstmal
alle daneben gelegen und das war für
mich hat den letzten jahr für dieses
jahr ein crash prognostiziert da habe
ich die korona virus kann nicht gekannt
einfach weil alle verrückt gespielt
haben angesichts der billigen geldern
mit denen die märkte geflutet sind und
ich mache mir riesensorgen auch einen
bereich den sie vorhin angesprochen
hatten
dass unsere altersvorsorge
zusammenbricht beispielsweise ganz kurz
noch bei den bei den st
bei den da kann man gleich noch dazu sie
haben sich die märkte sind geflutet
worden ezb das geld ist billig was
bedeutet das jetzt wenn die
realwirtschaft nicht abschmiert aber in
vielen teilen erhebliche schäden
erleidet was bedeutet eigentlich für die
banken die ja die kredite ausgereicht
haben an dieser ja wir haben zwei effekt
bewerben 1 durch das manipulierte
billige geld da spreche ich gar nicht
dagegen aber das ist faktum haben wir
einen anderen risiko preis bei den
einzelnen anlageklassen das
immobilienbereich das sehen wir überall
und es ist auch verständlich denn
derjenige der sein geld auf dem
sparkonto liegen hat wir jeden tag real
ärmer dass eine umverteilung die ganz
bewusst von der politik auch produziert
worden vielleicht produziert werden
musste vom gläubiger zum schuldner so
und das geht in die unternehmen hinein
die haben auch gute zeiten dadurch
erlebt das ist alles belebt worden und
jetzt plötzlich haben wir ein jahr vor
uns wo wir sagen müssen dieses jahr
bricht von den messeausstellern
angefangen von den taxiunternehmen flug
und so weiter einer nach dem anderen
wird das spüren und wir werden insolvenz
raten bekommen die die kreditinstitut
nicht eingeplant haben und unsere
kredite wurde werden schwierigkeiten
noch andere das spüren zum beispiel die
lebensversicherung abgeschlossen haben
das wird ja zum teil das ist gesetzlich
gibt es ja eine vorgabe ein teil dieser
anlagen wird in aktien gesteckt die
lebensversicherungen sind ja nicht mehr
das modell das man früher dass man so
früher vor sich hatte dass das eben das
alter absichert da gab es ja schon immer
schwierigkeiten mit den in den letzten
jahren muss man sagen schwierigkeiten
mit den renditen wird sich das weiter
verschärfen dieser zustand ich glaube
die der aktienanzahl bei den
versicherungen ist das geringste problem
ich glaube die anleihen quote die drin
ist wird das problem werden und man
sieht ja jetzt schon wieder das
gemunkelt wird oder eigentlich schon
fest steht dass der garantiezins sinkt
was nicht nur waren zu viel in den
festverzinslichen wertpapieren und in
den zehn schwachen anlagen der
garantiezins wird ermittelt unter
anderem an also das wird sich orientiert
an der deutschen bundesanleihen negativ
und das wird sich auch über lesen ja
auch nicht verbessern das heißt
eigentlich könnte man auch sagen kommen
die garantie zinssenkung wie lassen
direkt mal weg und wir verzichten auf
garantien
was aber nicht nur auswirkungen haben
wird für neuverträge sondern auch für
altverträge denn wenn sie denn große
versicherer einen bestand haben mit
garantiezinsen dennoch 3 oder
zweieinhalb prozent verspricht sie
können es wahrscheinlich bestätigen
im schnitt unter wirtschaft war aber -
mit einem großteil von meinem geld oder
mit dem teil
dann ist die frage wie viel überschüsse
kann ich noch abgeben an meiner
versicherer und da kann man nur dringend
ja sagen sogar stark reguliert dieser
markt dass man sagt also eigentlich
können die lebensversicherer die ein
versprechen an ihre kunden geben
durch die regulierung in diese so
genannten sicheren anlagen eigentlich
diese versprechen gar nicht mehr
aufrechterhalten zu stark reguliert kann
er im moment nicht sein wenn man ehrlich
ist haben wir eben darüber gesprochen
dass das ein risiko wäre wenn jemand
jetzt stark im aktien man drin ist dabei
eine gewisse einlage halten muss einfach
weil er sie zur verfügung braucht so
gesehen ist zum derzeitigen zeitpunkt
wurde beim genau auf diesen gedanken
wahrscheinlich nicht kommen
zuvor war ja immer der gedanke ob
pensionskassen lebensversicherer oder
auch stiftungen eben mehr aktienquote
oder höhere aktienquoten haben dürfen um
eben mehr erwirtschaften zu können
aber wir sehen eben genau bei so einem
kurssturz herz dass das ein risiko ist
was in einer gewissen höhe nur getragen
zu dem thema gehört auch der bereich
betriebliche altersversorgung das ist ja
eine dieser säulen zur gesetzlichen
altersversorgung dazu die betriebliche
und dann auch noch die private
altersvorsorge die man hier auch über
aktien machen
bei dieser betrieblichen altersvorsorge
die ja ganz wichtig ist gerade in zeiten
in denen die gesetzt dass gesetzliche
renten niveau nicht mehr so ganz sicher
ist jedenfalls dass es weiter steigt
und das ist zu auskömmlichen lebensabend
reicht was bedeutet jetzt ein solcher
kurssturz bei den aktien für
pensionskassen für all die die da geld
für ihre mitglieder anlegen die ja über
jahrzehnte da entweder an sparen oder
der betrieb bezahlt das und die
natürlich mit diesem geld auch rechnen
wenn meine antwort wird sie überraschen
fast nichts
und zwar deshalb weil es nichts weil die
lebensversicherung die haben die grenzen
die wir gesetzt hatten im pfarrer
gerhard und aufsichts gesetz für die
versicherungen die haben die alle nicht
ausgeschöpft jan zwar noch am weitesten
am mutigsten mit dabei und bei den
pensionskassen das recht so gewesen
nicht die sind alle auf nummer sicher
gegangen kann die dritte leihgeräte
bundesanleihe sich gekauft ein paar
andere staatsanleihen und plötzlich sind
sie im zins bis zu 30 jahren negativ
nicht das kann man sich natürlich
vorstellen was das für eine betriebliche
altersvorsorge heißt wenn die
pensionskassen ihr geld angelegt haben
in bundesanleihen nicht die keine
rendite erwirtschaften wenn die rein
gegangen wären in aktien
dann würde der korona virus auf 30 jahre
keine große rolle spielen
das ist ja das problem heutzutage dass
wir deutschen ist nicht schaffen zu
verstehen wie ein börsenmarkt
funktioniert und wie in crash
funktioniert und dass man wenn man sein
geld anlegt in einer garantierten
lebensversicherung und 0,9 prozent
wahrscheinlich in zukunft 0,4 oder 0,5
prozent garantiezins dann erreichen mit
hundertprozentiger sicherheit mein ziel
nicht
das heißt wir müssen das paradigma woran
messen wir risiko das müssen wir neu
denken dass wenn ich das sage
lebensstandard sichern
dann bin ich in aktien in
anführungszeichen weil ich die mit
höherer wahrscheinlichkeit wenn ihnen
guten sparplan mache durch die
diversifikation in den produkten und in
der zeit mein ziel erreiche was ich mit
einer triple r geräten bundesanleihen
wenn die 30 jahre ist heute mit
sicherheit nicht erreichen also und
tatsächlich ist es ja so dass wir nach
wie vor die situation haben dass wir
2000 milliarden euro in deutschland in
tagespflege an papieren haben also auf
ein girokonto um sparkonto
da glaube ich das geld konto die leute
haben 2000 milliarden euro da liegen und
haben nur ein paar hundert millionen in
aktien und fonds also von daher
sozusagen für die gesamte
vermögensbilanz ist das erst mal nicht
so ein problem und für die betriebliche
altersvorsorge ist das problem derzeit
tatsächlich dass sie nicht wachsen wird
daher sind die probleme und man muss
auch mal gucken wer denn jetzt wirklich
das problem hat die zahl der aktionäre
in deutschland liegt bei elf prozent
glaube ich nur mit mit den fondsanlegern
sind es bei 14
allein hat sich oprah die bundesbank
statistik noch mal genug
alleinerzieherinnen mit aktien gibt es
nicht arbeit damit aktien gibt es
praktisch auch nicht leute mit dir mal
arbeitslos waren mit aktien gibt es auch
nicht im osten gibt es landkreises
überhaupt keine aktionäre gibt das heißt
wir haben schon da ne eine auswahl und
die haben natürlich aber alle trotzdem
und das ist der reale kern
sie haben mit dem realen kern der krise
zu kämpfen weil die verlieren nämlich
ein arbeitsplatz und die machen sich
viel also jetzt mal die machen sich viel
mehr sorgen auch bei den leuten die bei
uns anrufen die machen sich viel mehr
sorgen darum wie sich ein job erhalten
können auch der kleine mittelständler
das hotel
der schreiner der sozusagen vielleicht
auch mal messebau macht also die machen
sich sorgen
der ist der lufthansa die anruft und
sagt mir haben sie gerade gesagt ich
soll jetzt mal zwei monate unbezahlten
urlaub nehmen
das heißt diese elf prozent aktienbesitz
da in deutschland das ist aber in
anderen ländern anders
das heißt wir haben ein spezielles
deutsches problem ja und ich glaube da
muss der deutsche staat in irgendeiner
form mit dazu beitragen man sieht ja in
den skandinavischen ländern ja der
norwegische staatsfonds der größte
verein der welt und dort wird dem bürger
oder auch in anderen skandinavischen
ländern freigestellt macht selbst was
oder wir machen uns für dich und dann
liegt die aktienquote ich weiß nicht was
gerade ist aber bestimmt noch bei 50 60
prozent und da ist es genauso natürlich
als er spontan glaube ich zu unserer
rentenversicherung deutlich besser
verzinst gut dass die frage ist müssen
wir dann in deutschland wenn jetzt da
nur 11% aktienbesitzer da sind und diese
abstoßungsreaktion diese vorsicht
gegenüber aktien so weit entwickelt ist
das
verhältnis zu unseren aktien neu denken
der börsenguru andré kostolany hat mal
gesagt die deutschen sind der tücke des
geldes nicht gewachsen das land der
romantiker ist in geldangelegenheiten
völlig unromantisch und hat keinerlei
einhaltung und keiner der hand zur
fantasie ist das ein deutsches problem
es ist zumindest hier wirklich ein
problem und ich muss auch ein professor
berger zustimmen dazu gehört auch dass
wir risiko hier immer noch abenteuerlich
bewerten also anlagen die wirklich hoch
risikoreich insofern sind dass sie einen
ganz sicheren verlust mit sich bringen
sind immer noch sehr sehr sichere
anlagen bei uns und umgekehrt sind
aktien hochgefährlich und vor allen
dingen sind sie entsprechend auch durch
die durch die medien durch die politik
die wir haben
sie bleiben gefährlich also sieht man
nimmt sie gar nicht anders war und als
ich eben sagte man kann die quoten gar
nicht gewöhnen in so einer zeit das hat
mit unserer einstellung mit unserem
unseren kenntnissen zu tun und es hat
damit zu tun dass das risiko bei diesen
versicherern auch so gerettet wird das
hier eben eine unglaublich hohe
sicherung für ein solches risiko das sie
eingehen hinlegen müssen das müssten sie
ja nicht wenn wir sie anders bewerten
also aufklärung tut hier immer noch not
in diesem land aber völlig richtig bei
der chor aber natürlich ist es auch so
dass die protagonisten in diesem bereich
also sowohl die versicherer als auch
besonders die banken nun auch nichts
dazu beigetragen haben dass das anders
wird
also wenn man sich das anschaut wir
haben jetzt zehn jahre tatsächlich
börsen horst gab und die aktienquote ist
nicht aufgegangen und wenn sie versucht
haben bei einer bank ein indexfonds zu
bekommen dann haben die gesagt kauf ein
mischfonds mit zwei prozent kosten
praktisch ohne rendite das heißt die
leute haben dort seit zehn jahren
praktisch keine rendite gesehen wir
haben wir müssen gar nicht noch mal über
die deutsche bank reden also sozusagen
die haben in einem jahr früher an boni
ausgeschüttet an ihre mitarbeiter was
die bank heute noch wert ist und
dividenden schütten die ja schon lange
nicht mehr aus also der umgang
derjenigen die das vermeintlich
professionell für uns machen mit diesem
problem
hatten jedenfalls nicht geholfen um das
mal ganz vorsichtig zu sagen habe ich
mache das jetzt noch an einer stelle
weiter wir reden jetzt aber haben wir
die finanzmarkttransaktionssteuer
geredet weil das du das schlecht ist für
den aktien mal bin ich ja dabei
unterschreibe ich jederzeit aber wenn
ich bei der volksbank dem uni global
kaufen was der standard von ist dann ist
die ausgabe auf statt das heißt das was
die volksbank einstreicht vorneweg 50
mal so hoch wie diese steuer
wo sind wir denn wie soll denn so was
dann hier funktionieren also das müsste
dann ja auch vielleicht anders geregelt
werden vielleicht macht das würde das
dann auch der wettbewerb machen
wir haben ja auch auf absehbare zeit
wird ist das richtig sehe ja
niedrigzinsphase das heißt die
klassischen anlageformen werden zu wenig
abwerfen
das heißt wenn man es gibt ja auch eine
gewaltige vermögensverschiebung von den
sparern zu den anlegern oder zu denen
die an der börse tätig sind also
praktisch der weg vom sparbuch zum
aktienfonds scheint ja vorgezeichnet zu
sein und trotzdem halten sich viele
leute zurück diese 2000 milliarden die
da auf sparkonten ruhen ist nicht wenig
aber diese idee daraus mehr geld zu
machen die ist hier zu wenig entwickelt
ja ich glaube das liegt an der historie
wir sind mit garantien aufgewachsen und
wenn man mal verhaltenspsychologie
schaut man sich die finanzielle
risikobereitschaft bildet dann fängt das
im mutterbauch an und bis zum frühen
erwachsenen sein bis man eine ausbildung
oder ein studium anfängt und wir sind in
der zeit aufgewachsen bewusst für
garantien 56 prozent noch gab wo es auf
dem tagesgeldkonto 4 prozent gab und ich
glaube wenn man so aufgewachsen ist dann
fällt es natürlich rein psychologisch
schwer sich davon zu trennen und die
lösung dafür ist aufklärung wie das über
verbraucherportale gemacht wird über
medien einfach die kenntnis zu haben
dass man über 15 jahre mit einem messer
gold etf keinen verlust machen kann das
ist eine garantie ich habe bisher über
15 jahre damit kein plus gemacht über 20
jahre schon gar nicht über 25 jahre ab 4
prozent gemacht vorher mindestens und
ich glaube das muss in erster linie
bewusst sein und dann muss man die leute
darüber aufklären und 50 prozent musste
zwischendrin mal aushalten und im
zweifel nicht immer ausnahmefällen aber
auch mal zehn jahre durststrecke
sitzenbleiben dornröschenschlaf
aber all das was jetzt auf ca
das schulde aufgezählt hat das ist bei
uns ja nicht vorhanden da fehlt diese
dna im umgang mit der börse und mit
anderen formen der geldanlage wenn das
sozusagen schon mit der muttermilch
eingesogen wird bleibt das dann bei
dieser situation in deutschland das sich
viele gewinne entgehen lassen und lieber
auf stagnation oder sogar auf dieser
liste setzen
ja das wird lange zeitdauer nicht man
jetzt wird man durch schaden klug
allmählich und das jetzt sieht ja auch
man muss aber auch fairerweise 1 dazu
sagen wir machen andere system gehabt
als andere länder nicht das hängt mit
der großen bedeutung zusammen die bei
uns die gesetzliche rentenversicherung
hat die ist einfach wichtiger gewesen
als in anderen ländern und zwischen sie
mich anschauen als beamter nicht
ich habe eine tolle funktion nicht da
kann man gut von leben nicht nur wer
zahlt die nicht die wird quasi aus dem
steueraufkommen bezahlt und dies nicht
an gesammelt worden so das system
funktioniert solange nicht die
antibabypille gehabt hat so haben und
jetzt haben wir ein buch drinnen einmal
in der generationen abfolge die baby
boomer kommen
wir sorgen nicht vor die politik denkt
in fünf jahres perioden und nicht in 20
30 jahren und wir kriegen generationen
krieg wenn wir so weitermachen also das
heißt die betriebliche und die private
altersvorsorge stream an bedeutung
gewinnen und sie muss rentabler werden
und das geht auf den weg dass man in der
zeit in riskanteren in anführungszeichen
gut gestreuten aber zielführenden
vermögensklassen an liegt und das wird
der bürger lernen aber hat er denn
überhaupt das geld was da jetzt zur
verfügung stünde was da so dann brach
liegt diese zwei und diese 2000
milliarden
kann man denn überhaupt eine börse
entsprechend viele anlagen davon kaufen
oder ist dass sie zu viel geld
eigentlich für das was die börse hergibt
was muss man sich das vorstellen wenn
jetzt ein großteil dieser dieser geld
plötzlich an der börse landen würden
glaube die börse würde das sehr gut
verkraften und es wird sich ja
vielleicht auch ein professor gehrke
deutete das von an eine gelegenheit
geben gerade durch so einen rücksetzer
dass der eine oder andere vielleicht auf
die idee kommt zu sagen ich schaue mir
das mal an ganze zwar angesprochen
es wird viele viele sehr gute
unternehmen geben die sehr viel
aufnehmen können wir haben ja grosse
unternehmen an der börse
blue chips die wirklich bedeutsam sind
und die unglaublich geld aufnehmen
können und das wäre doch eine schöne
idee sich dort mal an jetzt gerade in
dieser zeit um zu schauen vielleicht
nicht ins fallende messer wie man an der
börse sagt direkt zugreifen
so warten bis ruhe in den markt kommt
bis ein bisschen die idee davon hat wie
es wirtschaftlich weiter geht und dann
vielleicht wirklich sich mal unternehmen
anschauen von dem man ein bisschen was
versteht und die man schätzt und sich
überlegen ob man in diesem bereich mal
angeht aber wie war gestreut über einen
etf einsteigen
zweimal gefallen das sind glaube ich
aktien die sich am aktienindizes im
index der aktien also an der kurzen das
ist ein fond und in dem fonds stecken
einfach ganz ganz viele aktien drin also
normalerweise die weltweiten das sind
dann die wir bauen den msi nach das sind
1600 aktien weltweit an denen man quasi
mit 25 euro parallel beteiligt ist
man kann so ein fond auch für den dax
kaufen und sind die 30 deutschen dann
hat man wieder mehr risiko wenn man in
deutschland aber welt man kann das
weltweiten machen und man sollte das tun
das habe ich ja schon ein paar mal
gesagt und ich finde was man den leuten
vor allen dingen mal klar machen muss
jenseits der 2000 milliarden die sind ja
häufig an anderen stellen schon sehr
sicher abgesichert und zwar insbesondere
diejenigen die sich die sorgen machen
100.000 euro auf dem tagesgeldkonto
haben die haben häufig eine immobilie
was schon sicherer ist die haben eine
pension oder sie haben sozusagen eine
rente die sie erwarten die auch nicht so
niedrig ist und interessanterweise wenn
man sich ja jetzt anschaut wer sind denn
die aktionäre und die leute die fonds
kaufen dann sind es familiäre die haben
die höchste quote von 1
interessanterweise noch vor unternehmern
und dann kommen die beamten
und ganz am ende kommen angestellt und
klassisch arbeitnehmer haben gar keine
die eigentlich zur aufstockung ihrer
altersversorgung genau das ist auch noch
genau ist ein nachteil der börse dass
sie zur überhitzung neigt also so wie es
kursstürze gibt gibt es auch immer
wieder über hitze um die ja meistens
dann vor den kursstürzen stattfindet ist
das ein problem kann man das in den
griff kriegen ein anderer großer der
branche
buffett hat man gesagt sei an es war
ängstlich wenn andere gierig sind und
sei gierig wenn andere ängstlich sind
also diese zweite fall tritt er jetzt
offenbar gerade ein ist das kann man das
irgendwie anders in den griff kriegen
weil viele haben ja vor dieser
überhitzung den letzten monaten gewarnt
nein also kann man nicht man könnte das
geld zu aktiven verwaltern geben die
einen versprechen das besser zu machen
und die statistik zeigt dass das nicht
klappt sondern man muss mit dem risiko
leben und das was ihr geld angesprochen
haben abwarten könnte man man kann
einzelne unternehmen investieren oder
besser weltweit gestreut und ich würde
auch gar nicht abwarten wenn ich jetzt
100.000 euro investieren möchte oder
50.000 euro dann investiere ich jetzt
einmal im märz einmal im mai einmal im
juli sie das konsequent durch hat einen
schönen mittelpreis habe vielleicht
viele schlussverkäufe hatte den sparplan
interaktion sparplan man aber auch aber
auch wenn man einmalig geld hat also
jetzt nicht nur auf 20 jahre
das immer kontinuierlich zu machen
sondern auch jetzt zu sagen ich streue
das mal auf 10 12 36 verschiedenen
zeitpunkten und hab immer schön
schlussverkauf und in zehn jahren aber
nicht drauf geguckt hat denkt man sich
hoch also war der korona was man da
überhaupt ja so viele gar nicht wissen
dass sondern auch die bei der
betrieblich unterstützten
vermögensbildung ja auch aktien fonds
und aktien sparpläne in aktien
investieren kann
gerke wir sollen also ein aus einem volk
von sparern soll ein sport erfolg ich
sage es noch mal zugespitzt von
spekulanten gemacht werden also
diejenigen die an der börse dann aktiv
sind und die blätter spekulieren haben
und dann sind sie keine spekulanten mehr
das sei das was ich versucht hatte ein
beispiel
aber diese zuspitzung müssen wir einfach
aus dem hinterkopf rausbringen
das macht spaß zu spekulieren und da
habe ich auch gar nichts dagegen und ich
gestehe auch selber für mich dass ich
nicht alles optimal mache weil für den
personaler macht er noch nicht dass man
ein land braucht das weiß ich nicht ob
das immer so ist nicht aber okay das ist
auch mein privatvergnügen nicht aber für
die altersvorsorge müssen wir den leuten
beibringen das ist keine spekulation der
ich langfristig in einem sparplan am
produktivvermögen dieses landes
beteiligt denn dieses land hat kluge
köpfe und es wird eine positive
entwicklung haben und wenn deutschland
nicht genug traut dann geht eine
europäische rein und wenn europa nicht
genau dann macht es weltweit und diesen
gedankengang zur einzubringen dass das
dann keine spekulation ist sondern eine
seriöse altersvorsorge ist ja bei einem
versicherungen noch nicht angekommen
die versicherung sind heute zu fünf
prozent so etwa und welcher da streut es
um die da oben sind sind bei 9 prozent
und die anderen bei 2 und weniger drin
er in aktien drin das ist eine
delegation wenn der zins negativ ist
aber dann kommt zu sicherheit und sagt
aber das problem ist ja wenn ich jetzt
auch darauf angewiesen bin und der
aktienkurs ist gerade unten dann habe
ich davon nichts also wer jetzt auf
seine altersversorgung vor allen dingen
auf aktien aufgebaut hat und am ersten
april in den ruhestand geht der wird
weniger haben als wenn er am ersten
februar in den ruhestand gegangen werde
ich hoffe dass niemand seine
altersversorgung ausschließlich als hin
aufbaut das wäre derzeit ein anteil das
worauf ich hinaus wollte sind zwar
tatsächlich diejenigen die man wegen ein
kleines vermögen haben und legen das
komplett in aktien und wissen dafür
müssen sie aber auch das auto was kaputt
geht und die waschmaschine gestatten
bezahlen das ist unglücklich so einem
moment führt dann dazu dass man sich
abwendet von aktion und sagt ich habe
jetzt ein verlust gemacht ich habe mein
geld aber gebraucht das ist ein
furchtbares investment es muss schon ein
teil sein der wirklich liegt und dann
ist das risiko wirklich überschaubar
weil wir tatsächlich eine stetig
steigende börsen haben über gewisse
zeiträume dann also setzt jetzt sind wir
noch immer in einem theoretischen tech
takten aufwärtskanal seit der
finanzmarktkrise obwohl wir uns so stark
zurück bewegt haben aber das ist eben
etwas längerfristig
und das meinte ich mit wenn man sein
geld braucht also ein gewisser
notgroschen sollte schon da sein der
nicht das heißt für die altersvorsorge
auch ich muss das schon begleiten nicht
das heißt dass in dem moment wo ich in
die rente gehe
wo sich auch wirklich möglichst in rente
draus machen je jünger ich bin desto
länger kann ich mein geld am anfang mal
riskanter anlagen langfristig anlegen
aber wenn ich dann in die rente reingeht
dann macht es nun wirklich keinen sinn
mehr und dass ich jetzt gerade vom
corona wir uns noch erwischt werden wir
dann sollte ich mir diesen zahlungsfluss
schon anschauen dass ich mir den
sicherheit also um geschichten dann in
sichere anlagen ich bin erstaunt weil
wenn ich also gerade wer in der
altersversorgung
denn wenn ich jetzt 65 bin oder 67 oder
so dann habe ich nach nachdem das
statistische bundesamt sagt ungefähr 20
jahre zu leben wenn ich den versicherern
zuhörer dann sagen die ich leb noch 30
jahre ich musst du musst nicht so als
wären die jopie heesters warum ich dann
sozusagen einem zeitpunkt wo ich in
rente gehe
aufhören soll mein geld an der börse
links haben wenn das über die langen
jahrzehnte doch eigentlich das
vernünftigste ist das verstehe ich nicht
ich würde jetzt immer sagen herr berger
hat ja völlig recht ich muss dafür
sorgen dass ich garantiert meine
brötchen kaufen und meine miete bezahlen
kann das ist sozusagen das ist bot neid
und wenn ich jetzt einer börse
erfolgreich gewesen bis 65 oder so und
sagen okay
den teil den ich brauche damit ich
garantiert meine miete bezahlen kann und
meine brötchen bezahlen kann den schicht
ich so um dass der auf jeden fall sicher
da ist und zur verfügung steht und da
bleibt hoffentlich was über damit ich
jenseits von brötchen auch mal ein
croissant leid mir leisten kann und
vielleicht auch noch mal in den hunsrück
fahren kann ich jetzt nicht von mallorca
ist in diesen zeiten nicht mehr so und
da brauche ich da habe ich doch geld
noch liegen und dieses geld würde ich
auch zu einem guten teil auch durchaus
an der börse lassen solange ich mich
damit beschäftigen kann warum denn nicht
war er denn je weil sie einen bestimmten
lebensstandard sichern wollen in dem
moment sie haben weniger laufendes
einkommen
das heißt sie müssen das ersetzen durch
einen einigermaßen sicheren
zahlungsfluss das heißt nicht dass die
finger von aktien lassen
aber sie müssen sich jetzt natürlich
anschauen ich habe vorher 30 jahre
riskant investieren können weil im bezug
erreichung lebensstandard dass gar kein
hohes risiko ist jetzt bin ich aber
angekommen
jetzt muss ich schon mal umdenken ich
muss sicher stellen dass ich meine das
was ich so eine woche das heißt dass
sich das gerücht ist ja was ihr vorhin
gesagt haben nicht dass gerade die
pensionäre die höchste aktienquote hatte
eigentlich umgekehrt das hat er hatte
ich ja gerne nochmal gesagt natürlich
diejenigen einmal weil sie zu wenig geld
zur verfügung haben bisher haben uns
diese sorgen immer die deutsche
rentenversicherung abgenommen mit der
gesetzlichen rente das ist
möglicherweise in zukunft nicht mehr so
wie ich das jetzt alles würde was man
eigentlich alles tun muss um sich zum
beispiel bei der altersvorsorge
dazu ist ja die aktie unter anderem auch
da nicht nur dann müsste man ja
eigentlich finanzmanager in eigener
sache sein dazu braucht man ein
finanzberater die sie wiederum coachen
ist das denn realistisch dass jemand als
die der großteil der bevölkerung mit
ihrem geld tatsächlich so umgeht dass
man sagt das muss ich jeden tag jeden
monat jedes jahr im blick haben und auch
mein vermögen entsprechend professionell
bieten kann das klingt ja schon relativ
kompliziert also man braucht nicht jeden
monat im blick haben muss mal kurz
abzuwehren so plastisch zu machen was
gerade gesagt wurde wenn sie 500.000
angespart haben um jeden monat dann am
ende 1000 euro raus nehmen dann
entwickeln sich die anderen 488.000 in
dem jahr auch wieder nach oben
von daher ich glaube das hat was mit den
ganz bildung zu tun das muss an den
schulen anfangen wie es so wie es in
anderen ländern auch versucht wir dann
auch gemacht wird da fängt es an es gibt
verbraucher institute
blogger es gibt youtube die durch alle
altersklassen genutzt wird und es gibt
zum beispiel was sie ja auch empfehlen
honorarberater die sich unabhängig darum
kümmern können es gibt den
verbraucherschutz und ich glaube in
summe muss man da an einen an einem
strang ziehen und versuchen die
finanzbildung in deutschland zu
verlassen
finde das ist echt nicht so kompliziert
also die gesetzliche rente läuft sowieso
so jetzt spare ich zusätzlich was an und
ich habe ein tagesgeldkonto damit ich
nie den dispo braucht die blöden 10
prozent bezahlen muss ich habe dieses
festgeldkonto kann mich das nächste auto
damit kaufen kann und dann habe ich in
meinem depot irgendwas zwischen 20 und
wie viele hunderttausend ist auch egal
und das kann ich im grunde stehen lassen
und dann kann ich mir überlegen wenn ich
65 bin oder wenn ich in rente gehe
so wie viel davon möchte ich den
garantiert zur verfügung haben und dann
macht macht das ganz genauso dann sage
ich ich nehme mir jedes jahr fünf
prozent daraus so und in das am anfang
des jahres 50.000 sind es 1 5 prozent
zweieinhalbtausend da kann ich dann
einmal schön von den urlaub fahren
nächstes jahr sicher wieder 545 die
laufen ja weiter genau wie sie gesagt
haben aber sind dadurch kompliziert
hinein wenn das alles nicht so
kompliziert ist warum machen es nur elf
prozent
weil wenn sie wenn sie zu wenn sie zu
ihrer bank kommen weil die ihnen sagt
sie dem kauf ein mischfonds mit
zweieinhalb prozent gebühren und
schichten den alle fünf jahre um damit
wir noch mal wieder fünf prozent
ausgabeaufschlag kassieren
entschuldigung aber ich das ist jetzt
sehr polemisch aber das passiert leider
dann heißt das zum ende der sendung
seien sie auf der hut und prüfen sie die
geschäftsbedingungen nach die gedanken
nicht dass sie da waren zu diesem thema
das jetzt im moment viele bewegt und
auch für klar stellungen und wie ist das
mit den aktien war gibt werden wir sehen
dann gebe ich dass sie da war am morgen
geht es hier weiter auch in der phoenix
runde thema corona virus und die angst
brauchen wir mehr gelassenheit bleiben
sie bei uns
[Musik]